SANDEEP DINESH: As you start
to build more and more services
on top of Kubernetes,
simple tasks
start to get more complicated.
For example, teams can't
create services or deployments
with the same name.
If you have thousands
of pod, just
listing them all
would take some time,
let alone actually
administering them.
And these are just the
tip of the iceberg.
In this episode of
"Kubernetes Best Practices,"
let's take a look at how
namespaces can make managing
Kubernetes resources easier.
So what exactly is a namespace?
You can think of a namespace
as a virtual cluster
inside your Kubernetes cluster.
You can have multiple namespaces
inside a single Kubernetes
cluster.
And they're all isolated
from each other.
They can help you and your teams
with organization, security,
and even performance.
In most Kubernetes
distributions,
the cluster comes out of the
box with the namespace called,
default. In fact, there are
actually three namespaces that
Kubernetes ships with, default,
kube system, and kube public.
Kube public really isn't
used for much right now.
And it's usually a good idea
to leave kube system alone,
especially in a managed system
like Google Kubernetes Engine.
This leaves the
default namespace
as the place where your
services and apps are created.
There's absolutely nothing
special about this namespace,
except that the Kubernetes
tooling is set up
out of the box to
use this namespace
and you can't delete it.
While it's great
for getting started
and smaller
production systems, I
would recommend against using
it in large production systems.
This is because it's
very easy for a team
to accidentally overwrite,
or disrupt another team
without even realizing it.
Instead, you should
create multiple namespaces
and use them to
segment your services
into manageable chunks.
Creating a namespace can be
done with a single command.
If you want to create a
namespace called test,
you would run kubectl
create namespace test.
Or you could create a YAML
file and apply it just
like any other
Kubernetes resource.
You can see all the namespaces
with the following command,
kubectl get namespace.
You can see the three built-in
namespaces spaces, as well as
the new namespace called test.
Let's take a look at a
simple YAML to create a pod.
You may notice that there
is no mention of a namespace
anywhere.
If you kubectl
apply on this file,
it'll create a pod in the
current active namespace.
This will be the default
namespace unless you change it.
Now, there's two ways
to explicitly tell
Kubernetes which namespace you
want your resource created in.
The first way, is using
the namespace flag
when creating the resource.
The second way is to specify
a namespace in the YAML
declaration.
Now, if you specify a
namespace in the YAML,
the resource will always be
created in that namespace.
If you try to use
another namespace
by using the namespace
flag, the command will fail.
Now, if you try
to find your pod,
you may have noticed
you can't find it.
This is because all
commands are run
against a current
active namespace.
To find your pod, you need
to use the namespace flag.
Now, this can get
annoying quickly,
especially if you're
a developer working
on a team that uses its own
namespace for everything
and don't want to use
the namespace flag
for every single command.
Let's see how we can fix that.
Out of the box, your
active namespace
is the default namespace.
Like we saw before,
unless you specify
a namespace in the
resource's YAML,
all Kubernetes commands will
use the active namespace.
Now unfortunately, trying to
manage an active namespace
with kubectl can be a pain.
Fortunately, there's a
really good tool called
Kubens that makes it a breeze.
When you run the
kubens command, you
should see all the namespaces
with the active namespace
highlighted.
To switch your active
namespace to the test namespace
you can just run kubens test.
Now you can see the test
namespace is active.
If you run kubectl
commands, the namespace
will now be test
instead of default.
This means you don't need
the namespace flag to see
the pod in the test namespace.
So namespaces are
hidden from each other,
but they're not isolated.
A service in one
namespace can talk
to a service in another
namespace pretty easily.
This can often be very useful.
For example, having your
service for your team
talk to another namespace
with another team's service.
Normally, when your app wants
to access a Kubernetes service,
you can just use the built-in
DNS service discovery
and just point your app
at the services name.
However, you can
create a service
for the same name in
multiple namespaces.
Thankfully, it's easy
to get around this
by using the expanded
form of the DNS address.
Services in Kubernetes
expose their endpoint point
using a common DNS pattern.
It looks like this.
Normally, you just
need the service's name
and DNS will automatically
resolve to the full address.
However, if you need to access
a service in another namespace,
just use the service name
plus the namespace name.
For example, if you want
to connect to the database
service in the
test namespace, you
can use the following
address database.test.
And if you want to
connect to the database
service in the
prod namespace, you
can use the following
address database.prod.
Of course, sometimes you do
want to isolate and limit access
to a namespace.
Kubernetes lets you do
this with network policies.
Stay tuned for a
future episode, where
we'll deep dive into these.
A common question I get is,
how many namespaces to create?
And for what purpose?
What exactly is a
manageable chunk?
If you make too many namespaces,
they'll just get in your way.
But if you make too few,
you'll lose the benefits.
I think there are four major
stages that each company goes
through and they have their
own organizational structure.
Depending on the stage that
your project or company is in,
you can adopt the relevant
namespace strategy.
So imagine you're part of a
small team that's working on
maybe 5 to 10 microservices and
you can easily bring everyone
into the same room.
In this situation,
it makes sense
to launch all production
services into the default
namespace.
You might want to have a
production and development
namespace, if you
want to get fancy.
But you know, you're probably
testing your development
environment on your local
machine using something
like Minikube.
Now, the scenario changes.
You have a rapidly
growing team that's
working a 10 or
more microservices.
It's necessary at
this point to use
multiple clusters,
or namespaces,
for production and development.
You may start to split the
team into multiple sub-teams
that each have their
own microservices.
And then each of
these teams might
choose their own namespace
for easier manageability.
While everyone might know how
the complete system works,
it's getting harder and harder
to coordinate every change
with everyone else.
Trying to spin up the full
stack on your local machine
is just getting more
complicated every day.
Now, at large companies everyone
doesn't know everyone else.
Teams are working on features
that other teams might not even
know about.
Now, teams are communicating
using service contracts
and maybe they're using
service meshes like Istio
to coordinate communication.
Trying to run the whole stack
locally is just impossible.
Using a Kubernetes aware
CD system like Spinnaker
is highly recommended.
And at this point,
each team definitely
needs their own namespace.
Each team might even opt
for multiple namespaces
to run their development
and production environments.
Setting up [? R-back ?] and
resource quotas is a good idea
as well.
And we'll cover those
in future episodes.
Multiple clusters start to
make sense at this point,
but they really might
not be necessary.
And finally, there are
large enterprise companies.
There are groups that don't
even know about the existence
of other groups.
Groups might as well be external
companies and services are
consumed through
well-documented APIs.
Each group has
multiple teams and have
multiple microservices.
Using all the tools I previously
mentioned are necessary.
And people should not be
deploying services by hand.
And in fact, they
should be locked out
of namespaces they don't own.
At this point, it
probably makes sense
to have multiple clusters
to reduce the blast
radius of poorly
configured applications
and to make billing and
resource management easier.
As the number of
microservices and teams
using Kubernetes in your
organization increases,
namespaces can really
make Kubernetes
a lot more manageable and
give you increased control,
security, and flexibility.
I'll see you on the next episode
of "Kubernetes Best Practices."